there are no straight men only men who
haven't met jack
oh my god look don't it's too easy
jack good you're still there yeah
i'm still waiting for that package
grace where did you get these drapery
panels um
emerald fabric why no reason are you
kidding me with this
okay the hand is perfect but it's more
are you kidding me with this hole
[Applause]
get a life
if i could turn back time
[Applause]
and i can turn back down
snap out of it
you can't just devastate me and kick me
out you're not my lover
help the man standing behind me with the
big package grace don't tease me
hello grace adler design i'll sign for
it
uh just your name sir i don't need your
phone number
don't be so sure sir
[Laughter]
you live with the hetero long enough
you're going to catch it
thank you thank you ladies and gentlemen
um my name is jack mcfarland
but for tonight i want you to think of
me as
just chad hi grace
hi first of all i still hate you and you
will be punished
about the whole harlem i was thinking on
the way to over here in the in the
camera yeah but
i think you should know okay well maybe
you should stop butting in for once
please
okay i was thinking that
maybe i was a little off the mark in my
design concept
and i'm so sorry for getting so angry
gracie hey lady you
lady at your life
you're a discontented mother
and a regimented
oh uh listen
harlan is here oh my god oh my god i
don't want to die
well um he liked the apartment
oh i've been to georgia and california
and anywhere i could run
took the hand of a preacher man and we
made love in the sun
[Music]
that actually happened to me
gracie please don't don't give me the
the squint i i admit that i have a
problem
my name is will t and i am a butter
inner i
i knew it look look what can i say you
were right
you could say that i just did oh maybe
again well you were right
i think i need to hear it i was wrong
[Music]
lady
you were right i was wrong hey hey it's
not the will and great show it's called
just jack
spring hello what's that i'm bored yeah
thanks for calling bye-bye
karen i haven't seen you this freaked
out since you turned 42
one 34 two one pretty girl pretty girl
hi belle you look pretty today jack
thank you i was thinking the same thing
myself
oh my god it's drugs
it's drugs he's doing drugs
without me
not that i do drugs but i'd like to be
asked
you know what else he wouldn't tell
either of us if he's sick
he needs a kidney oh my god he needs a
kidney
not that i would give him a kidney but
i'd like to be asked
kids come on it doesn't matter you two
are having a baby and well
we think it's wonderful thank you
i do ask that after you have completed
the act of making sweet sweet love
that you get will a one-way ticket back
to homoville before it gets too
comfortable in china heights
is this because i'm gay
you feel you failed somehow and now you
need to get a new baby and start all
over again
i'm gay and you're not my baby
it's just it it's just it's just that
the new baby's gonna come
and he's gonna be cuter than i am and
younger than i am and he's gonna have a
better job than i do
well sure but we'll still love you
i don't know well it's not gonna crazy
we'll still pay for you yay we're having
a baby
i'm done with men
2004 is all about women
who walk like men
men are hot i miss men
i'm back on medicine jack i'm asking you
to be my kid's godfather well or
rather his his fairy godfather
oh my oh my god
i'd be honored i'd be moved that pays
what like 100 200
a week it pays nothing
well then i'm just honored bert's gotta
fly
i gotta love one man till i die
can't help
tell me lazy tell me so tell me i'm
crazy
maybe i know i can't help loving that
man of mine
i'll take a jacket and pot a beret and
pot of beret and souffle
i'm gay you go
go keep an eye on barry he doesn't
understand how predatory some of these
guys can be
oh excuse me i see a defenseless
queerling who's wandered away from the
flock
jack and i are gonna have it painted
think if it's a girl and hot pink if
it's a boy
and flannel if it's a lesbian that was a
great game yeah
so want to hit the showers
what you know like they're doing
jack i don't think that's appropriate
what do you talk
it's just a couple of naked straight
guys soaping each other down
okay i i have to say something here the
back slapping and the head rubbing was
one thing
but the ear blowing and the butterfly
kisses are not standard nba practice
and now this shower thing what are you
implying
you're coming on to me
what i am shocked and appalled
but are you interested
you think that you can just come in here
and use this group
this group that puts people back on the
path of righteousness
as some kind of dating service i just
need a yes or no
no and i want to make something crystal
clear to you and to everyone else in
this room excuse me
we are here to lead normal heterosexual
lives
man and woman are meant to be together
so anyone here who has a misguided
notion that welcome back home
is some kind of a a gay pickup joint you
can just leave right now
well look at him go i haven't seen a
stampede like this since
pamplona oh my god listen to me i'm a
funny lesbian i'm ellen
as long as it's a heterosexual soap down
atta girl
you